he was a comic genius who had only one
speed setting and that was full throttle
for a moment he burst into our lives as
an alien on happy days he amazed us with
his range of talents it's utterly left
us breathless it binds the manic stick
of Robin Williams was a man who was
deeply plagued by depression he had
other demons such as alcohol and cocaine
as well still he kept us entertained to
the very end which made it all the more
unfathomable to his legion of fans and
admirers he took his life at the age of
just 63 in today's by graphics we intend
to get the essence of the real Robin
Williams Robin Maclaurin Williams came
into the world on July the 21st of 1951
born at st. Luke's Hospital in Chicago
Illinois he was the only child of Lori
and Robert Williams the family was
wealthy with Robert being a senior
executive at the Ford Motor Company
Lori was a former model and a part-time
actress much of Robins formative years
were spent alone in the huge mansion
that was his home in order to cope with
his loneliness he created characters and
conversations in his head he was an
overweight child which led to bullying
at school a sixth grade he later
recalled was the most difficult year of
his life many days he went on crying
after constant name-calling and physical
harassment each day was torment for him
with his only friends being the ones he
created in his own imagination these
difficult early years they brought on a
depression that Robin was to grapple
with for the rest of his life
Robin began by using comedy as a defense
mechanism it started with his mother
Lori he had a very sharp wit and would
often use humor laced with sarcasm to
communicate with her son in order to
connect with her Robin Hanson make his
mother laugh it wasn't good enough to be
Robin he had to be funny Robin by the
time he was 16 the family had relocated
to California where Robin attended
redwood high school it was the late
sixties and straight-laced Robin found
himself in the middle of a
counterculture that revolved around
drugs and sex he was able to loosen up
on after dabbling with marijuana found
himself fitting in
for the first time it was at redwood
high that Robin he stumbled upon the
drama department
he had already perfected his comedic
veneer quickly establishing a reputation
as the class clown
he felt totally in love with the idea of
improv performance his comedic
personality is slowly emerging through
drama classes at the same time Robin got
involved in wrestling and soccer proving
to be an accomplished athlete but by the
time he graduated in 1969 he was voted
by his classmates as least likely to
succeed not surprisingly though he was
also voted funniest students after
graduating he attended Claremont men's
College his sights they were set on a
career in political science before long
however he was spending more time in the
college theater than he was in lecture
rooms he won the coveted role of Fagin
and the college's production of Oliver
turning in a stellar performance that
made it clear that he was destined for
the limelight even behind his diplomatic
ambitions Robin involved in a community
college theatre program during classes
he would often improvise leaving his
classmates and teachers and fits of
laughter after three years of honing his
craft he was offered the opportunity of
a lifetime full scholarship to the
Juilliard School of Performing Arts in
New York City Robin was one of only two
students accepted into the 1973 advance
program that Juilliard the other while
that was future Superman actor
Christopher Reeve Reeve who had become
the close friend recalled his first
impressions upon meeting Williams he
wore tie-dye shirts with tracksuit
bottoms and talked to man a minute I've
never seen so much energy contained in
one person he was like an untied balloon
that had been inflated and immediately
released I watched in auras he virtually
kuranda off the walls of the class and
always to say that he was on would be a
major understatement a Juilliard well
Robin Lee he astounded his teachers and
fellow students alike he was able to
take on a persona of characters with
ease trading out one accent or dialect
for another like he was born to do it
however Robin he was frustrated at
Julliard he just didn't fit in after two
years his teachers told him that there
was nothing more that they could teach
him one of his instructors considered
Robins be a genius who was not being
properly served by the school's
conservative and classical training
style he left Julliard in 1976 to launch
himself onto the world his first stop
was the stand up circuit on the west
coast Robin's first break into the
realms of comedy came at a club in the
San Francisco Bay Area his first gig was
at the Holy City Zoo where he also spent
time tending bar
these early sense they were forensic
bordering on psychotic no one had ever
seen anything quite like Robin Williams
he played a collection of rather edgy
characters including Reverend oral
satisfaction his early stand-up was
influenced by the likes of Lenny Bruce
Peter Sellers and Jonathan winters his
manic edge quick-fire ad-lib routines
and off-the-wall physical comedy proved
an absolute hit and he soon established
a loyal following Robin loved the
immediate feedback that came with
stand-up comedy and it was something
that he would continue right through his
career despite the apparent ease of his
performances he actually found stand-up
incredibly stressful underneath the
cloak of his act he was an intensely shy
man he once said that he started using
drugs and alcohol as a crutch to combat
stage nerves in 1977 Williams he moved
to Los Angeles where he began performing
at the comedy club it was here that he
was discovered by TV producer George
Schlatter who offered him a spot in a
revival of the old 60s show Martha now
the show well it ultimately didn't
survive but for Williams it established
a foothold into a career in television
he became a semi-regular cast member on
the Richard Pryor show while also
continuing to perform stand-up it was an
appearance on the Richard Pryor show
that brought Williams to the attention
of Garry Marshall the producer of the
hit sitcom happy days after five years
the script writers well they were
running out of ideas but they they
hadn't yet jumped the shark they decided
to do an episode taking off the 1960s
sci-fi comedy my favorite Martian the
episode well it's called my favorite
Orca and it called for the casting of an
actor to play an alien from the land of
ork Marshall thought that Williams might
be the man for the job in what has gone
down as possibly the most brilliant
audition in TV history
Robin entered the room and
immediately sat in the chair on his hat
he continued to do his lines and then
broke into an inspired ad-lib Marshall
cast him on the spot later commenting
that Williams was the only alien who
turned up for the part the episode of
happy days it was originally shot as a
dream sequence on the part of Richie
Cunningham however the character played
by Williams a walk from ork was such a
hit with the TV watching audiences after
an initial broadcast that the ending was
refilmed so the Mork was a real
character bunch of Robins work on the
Happy Days episode was improvised and
augmented with physical comedy audiences
couldn't get enough of the zany alien
and demanded much more this led to the
creation of the spin-off series Mork &
Mindy which ran from 1978 to 1982 the
show catapulted Williams to absolute
stardom literally overnight after just
two weeks on the air
it had zoomed to the top ten of the
Nielsen ratings the producers of the
show they kept the script too loose
enough to give Robin plenty of room to
do as he pleased
anslee results were unpredictable
over-the-top and hilarious while the
critics they weren't overly enthused
with the show they weren't absolutely
falling over themselves to lavish praise
upon its star Vulcan Mindy it quickly
became a pop-culture phenomenon a
generation of kids took to warring
mork's trademark rainbow suspenders and
greeting their friends with the words
nano nano Robin went from relative
obscurity to instant fame in the space
of a couple of months it was something
that he was entirely unprepared for and
unfortunately it led to him indulging in
the excesses that come with fame drugs
alcohol and women just like he acted in
the fast lane he also lived his life in
the fastest of fast lanes he quickly
slipped into the habit of partying into
the early hours crawling home at 5 in
the morning and then having to be on set
by 10 a.m. there is no doubt though that
Robin he was blessed with more physical
energy than most inevitably however that
energy began to burn out he would
sometimes fall asleep on the set or just
sit dormant in off mode one night after
performing a late-night set at a comedy
club
Robin met up with fellow comic John
Belushi they ended up at the Chateau
Marmont where Robin's
some of Belushi's cocaine and then left
the next day on the set of Mork & Mindy
co-star Pam Dawber broke the news to
Williams that Belushi had died of a drug
overdose the news
well that shot him into making
significant changes in his lifestyle
death of Belushi tarnished the image of
Hollywood's fastest living Rat Pack
Robin was called to testify before a
grand jury an experience which along
with the shock of Belushi's death and
the birth of his first child Zach
allowed him to break free from the
stranglehold of drugs and alcohol it was
at this time that he discovered cycling
a form of exercise which he credits for
saving his life
after four years Mork and Mindy had lost
its Midas touch
producers tried whatever they could to
resurrect the initial appeal but nothing
seemed to work they decided to make more
less naive allowing Williams to work in
more of his nightclub act material
interestingly the more character also
found its way into his stand-up routines
though not by Robins design audience
members at late-night shows which simply
yell out to Mork switch Robin would
frustratingly responds am orcs not here
I'm a different guy by the middle of
1982 though the character that had
propelled Williams to superstar status
was beginning to feel like a millstone
around his neck so it came as somewhat
of a relief to him when Mork and Mindy
was canceled after four seasons in 1976
Robin met Valerie Velarde while working
as a bartender in San Francisco shortly
after leaving Julliard she was a dancer
having studied at Juilliard herself they
began a relationship and after two years
were married on between the fourth 1978
valerie's she endured her husband's
cocaine addiction and wild partying
lifestyle for a number of years as we
mentioned though among other things it
was the birth of his son Zachary on
April the 11th 1983 that led him to
finally shake off his addictions however
there was one thing that he was not able
to control and that was his wandering
eye he ended up having an affair with a
cocktail waitress by the name of
Michelle Tisch car tap then in 1986 miss
Carter sued Williams for 6.4 million
dollars claiming that he had knowingly
infected her with herpes simplex virus
he settled out of court only for his
wife to sue for divorce a few months
later on April the thirty
of 1989 less than a year after his
divorce from Valerie being finalized
Williams married
Basia Grimes the former nanny to his son
Zack they had actually been carrying on
an affair during the last two years of
his previous marriage at the time of the
wedding Vasya was pregnant with Robyn's
trials a daughter who they named Zelda
Rae two years later they had a second
child Cody Allen the marriage it lasted
19 years / musya finally left after she
realized she wasn't able to handle
Robyn's relapse into addiction Williams
he married for the third and final time
in 2011 this was to Susan Schneider who
was a graphic designer at the time he
met her while recovering from a heart
operation in 2009 they were still
together at the time of his death in
[Music]
Robyn's Fame on the small screen it
inevitably aroused the interests of
movie makers his first starring role
came in the 1980s Popeye the movie there
was a financial and critical flop and it
looked like Williams's film career was
over before it really gotten started but
then in 1982 the world according to GARP
he was able to show more of his dramatic
acting talents the film it was well
received with critic Roger Ebert calling
Robyn's performance unconventional and
absorbing following a couple of smaller
roles he got his big-screen break in
1987's good morning Vietnam this role
was Adrian Cronauer a real-life Armed
Forces DJ stationed in Saigon during the
war it was tailor-made for Williams's
manic style in fact nearly everything
that he did on-screen was totally
improvised the performance it was good
enough to earn him an Academy Award
nomination for Best Actor over the next
decade Williams appeared in an
impressive number of films displaying a
huge range and appeal across the
generations he's shown as both a
dramatic and a comic actor with his
first and only Oscar coming for best
supporting actor playing a psychologist
in 1997's
Good Will Hunting he had previously
received two nominations for 1988 Dead
Poets Society and 1991's the Fisher King
perhaps Williams's most versatile role
was one in which he never actually was
on screen though it was his role as the
genie in the 1992 Disney animated
physical Aladin the role had been
specifically written to him although he
improvised much of the dialogue just as
he had done in good morning Vietnam
Williams went on to play what would be
his most beloved character in 1993 in
mrs. Doubtfire in this movie he
portrayed a recently divorced actor who
takes on the persona of an elderly
Scottish housemaid to get closer to his
children he spent four hours every day
putting on his makeup to play the part
well the movie it was a great success
and a sequel was actually in the works
at the time of Williams's death in 2014
his darkest role it came at two thousand
and twos one-hour photo Williams played
a lonely photo technician he becomes
obsessed with a family whose photos he
has developed for years he received rave
reviews from such esteemed critics as
Leonard Melton and Roger Ebert Robbins
last parents on the big screen was in
2014 night of the museum secret of the
tomb in which he reprised his role as
President Theodore Roosevelt in the 2015
film absolutely anything he provided the
voice of Dennis the dog it closed out a
38 year career that encompassed 74
movies in 1966 together with fellow
celebrity Whoopi Goldberg and Billy
Crystal Robin founded comic relief USA
the charity helps the homeless with
eighty million dollars being raised as
of last year together with his second
wife he also created the windfall
foundation to help donate money to a
variety of causes including some Jude
Children's Research Hospital on May the
27th 1955 Robin's close friend
Christopher Reeve was thrown from a
horse and paralyzed
Robin drops everything and rushed to be
at his bedside he turned up in full
costume as a crazed Russian doctor
giving Reeve at the first laugh since
his tragic accident Robin would go on to
donate huge sums to research into spinal
cord injury when Reeves died in 2004
Robin was absolutely devastated Williams
was also passionate about supporting the
military he traveled and performed at
many bases around the globe and he was
well known as a modern-day Bob Hope
during his career he entertained over a
hundred thousand troops in 13 countries
[Music]
Williams managed to quit alcohol and
cocaine in the early 1980s however in
2003 he lapse back into alcohol abuse
while working on the movie the big white
on location in Alaska for the next three
years he denied that he had a problem
finally he was confronted by family and
friends who convinced him to check
himself into a substance abuse
rehabilitation center in Newberg Oregon
there he finally admitted that he was an
alcoholic after 60 days in rehab rather
than returning to his family Robyn began
living with a sober companion who was
charged with ensuring that he didn't
relapse it was shortly after that that
his wife Marcia left him a depressed
Robyn did what he always did to get by
when life got tough he threw himself
into his work going on tour to do
stand-up but unfortunately in the middle
of this tour it was discovered that he
needed heart surgery the operation it
went well but it required quiet rest in
order to recuperate this forced time of
inactivity allowed the demons in his
head to have free reign
Williams's addictive personality led to
marathon cycling and video gaming
sessions cycling was a healthy obsession
for him but for a man who struggled with
depression his whole life being alone in
a room with a computer was very
dangerous
shortly after this he began drinking
again this time he didn't care who knew
in May of 2014
Williams's a new TV show the crazy ones
was cancelled after just one season edge
aligned he was back in rehab it was
around that time that he also learned
that he had Parkinson's disease after
his death it was discovered that what
had been diagnosed as Parkinson's was
actually Lewy body dementia after his
death Robyn's wife Susan revealed that
Robyn had been having severe and
prolonged episodes of fear and anxiety
insomnia constipation stress and hand
tremors that have been going on for over
a year
she said that he would constantly tell
her I just want to reboot my brain on
August the 11th 2014 Robin Williams
committed suicide by hanging himself
with a belt he died from asphyxiation
his wife Susan stated that he was killed
by the terrorists inside my husband's
brain within hours of the tragic news of
his passing thousands of fans were
posting images of themselves standing on
their desks with the caption Oh captain
my
captain in reference to Robins character
in Dead Poets Society it was a fitting
tribute and a beautiful standoff to this
brilliant man so I really hope you found
that video interesting and inspiring if
you did please do thumbs up button below
and don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos on this channel
biographies of all sorts of people from
history whether Robin Williams - all
sorts of different things from
politicians serial killers
businesspeople running the gamut anyway
you can check out some more of those
that are over there on the right and
don't forget to subscribe and thank you
for watching